- [Voiceover] Previously on
the Adventure Men who Try.
- We still got talking cats?
I am down.
- We've never done cosplay before.
(screams)
- We do have an opening act, though.
- You guys should definitely
feel some pressure.
- Have you seen a lot of post-apocolyptic
- Punk rock
- '80s glam
- Meets dudes
- Sailor scouts before?
- No.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] So, with the
aid of the talking cat friend,
our brave adventure men set forth
on a journey to Anime Expo,
determined to be the best cosplayers
this world has ever seen.
- [All] Make-up!
- [Voiceover] The Try Guys try cosplay
Episode 3: The Try Guys
Cosplay for the First Time.
Oh my God.
- We are here at the beautiful
L.A. Convention Center.
- It's crazy already.
- [Keith] There's a hundred
thousand people here today,
it's nuts.
- What's up Anime Expo 2K15!
Oh man, I've been practising
that for the masquerade.
- I'm excited for the masquerade,
we found out there's a 40-foot LED screen
behind us.
- It's like a giant stage, and
there are lights and stuff.
- I'm like a stickler for,
like, you know perfection,
like I want everything to be on point.
- Hopefully we don't f*** it all up.
- Ow!
Probably gonna f*** somethin' up.
- This whole process leading up
has been really tough.
Building these costumes takes a long time
and a lot of effort.
- People here are legit.
- Just driving up we saw
like really, like to-the-tee
costumes of, like, anime characters.
- You see people that you know
and you're like, "What's
up Wario! Love the belly!"
- [Zach] People obviously
have been putting a lot
of time and care on their costumes,
just working for months for this one day.
- It's not just a hobby for people,
but it's a lifestyle.
- In the name of the
moon, stay on your head.
- I am a beautiful galaxy princess.
So we're here with Tim Wyckoff,
Tim, what are we getting
ourselves into today?
- So much.
So freakin' much.
You guys are about to go out to
the largest anime
convention in North America,
hundred thousand people
looking insanely awesome.
People are going so happy
you're not going to be able to walk.
People are going to scream.
We have screamers at Anime Expo, oh yeah.
- I'm super excited to get into the fray
of everybody else dressed up.
- Gettin' anxious, I
just wanna get out there.
- [Keith] I feel really
proud about the costume.
- All these little
pieces all came together.
- [Ned] I had so much
fun making our costumes,
like I'm so proud of what we did.
And I'm just like, I'm so
excited to just get out there
and show off what we did to people.
No, what we did, I'm excited
to show off what we did,
comma to people.
It made sense.
It's a sentence.
- I wanna play DDR.
That's all I wanna play.
- Hhh, it's a tuxedo mask, hey!
So we were out there
for about half an hour.
- Don't play this game, I hate it!
- Oh God, it's so fast!
- And then all of our costumes
started falling apart.
- My wig keeps falling off my head!
- Let's be careful because we're already
losing parts of the costume.
- [Ned] It's hard enough to
just assemble your costume
for the first time, but then you have to
maintain it all day!
- The second we walked out the door
my bubble gun stopped working.
We may have to hold off.
- Also, within 30 minutes,
I started getting hurt
by Eugene's horrific bow.
- Sorry, sorry about my fire bow.
Sorry, it's my fire bow.
Sorry I have a very spiky fire bow.
Oh, there's a baby.
Ah, my fire bow!
- Ow!
I told you about that!
- just wanted to do cosplay good.
- I mean, it's really fun,
there's lot of people that
are excited to see us,
that's great, we're just hoping
to keep our costumes up to par.
Also earlier Eugene said that
Ned looked like a lesbian.
- What?
- That's a compliment
in the highest order,
but now we're gonna actually
go to the main floor
and do like real cosplay
posing and interacting.
After we figure out how to
make everything stick to us
without falling off.
- How many photos do you
think that we can expect
to take today?
- Thousands.
And I'm not kidding.
- Where's the camera?
Who's got the camera?
- As soon as you stop to
take pictures with someone,
you're gonna be stopped there
for probably a good 20 minutes.
- What?
- Everybody, everybody can get a picture,
we're down!
- You're the living embodiment
of their favorite thing.
- Yeah, goku, super sane guys.
- I wanna take a picture with Darth Maul!
- That is one of those
things about cosplaying
for animation or comic books,
they don't exist in real life,
those people are on a page.
You're bringing them to life.
- We all agree that Sailor
Mars is the best, right?
- I'm so excited that you made this yours.
You took something classic,
you took Sailor Moon,
you turned it into something
that you believe in
that you have fun with, and that's
what cosplay's about: having fun.
- You know what my favorite part
of the entire experience was?
- Our Sailor Venus here talking
to people on a fake mike.
- What's your name?
What's your name?
Speak into the microphone!
- Ahh!
- What?!
- So we're gonna just
take a break real quick,
before we go down and do
an official photo shoot
with our cosplay sempai.
- Oh, that's what we're doing next, cool.
- So what is involved in making
a great cosplay photo shoot?
- Great costumes, good location.
Yeah, a lot of gettin' into
the feel of your character,
maybe practise a little
bit in front of the mirror
so you kind of know
your body a little bit.
- I know a lot about Keith's body.
- I know a lot about Eugene's body.
- I know a lot about his body.
- Very pillowy, Keith.
- Thank you.
- Just have fun, relax.
Just be silly.
- Alright so sempai, you
gotta tell us what to do
and how to pose.
- Who's the cutesy one out of the group?
- He's the cutesy one.
- Be more cutesy!
Think Destiny's Child.
Make love to the camera.
Be Boyonce, give 'em some Blue Seal,
yeah, really serious.
Make sure your hair is right.
- Is my hair right?
- That's a part of cosplay, you have to
become your character.
You guys are getting really good at this.
- Now give us some Kuwai!
- Wee!
(laughter)
Hit me in the face!
- So we're also gonna be performing
at the masquerade at the Anime Expo.
We're the opening act.
- Wow.
- Wait, we're opening?
Hold, hold up,
that is news to me.
- We're opening the show.
- What since when?
We've never done it
and we're gonna say
"This is how you do it"?
- [All] We're judging?!
- We have to be really...
- Well, a question any judge should ask,
what is the masquerade?
What is it?
- Is this it?
- This is it.
- Let's do this.
- So every con has a masquerade,
which is basically, it's a competition.
- Wait so is it like a beauty pageant,
where you walk across stage,
or is there a performance involved?
- Well, both.
People can sign up and show their skills,
show off their costumes, and win awards,
and then there're skits
where someone, who maybe did Elsa
will sing "Let it Go" in costume.
So it's a chance to make a
performance and be the character
and bring them to life a little bit more.
- Oh man, I don't even
know about the masquerade.
- Is there someone we
need to be talking to
about where the placement
is of everything?
- So I have no had the time
to practise the dance or the sketch.
- I'm excited, but I'm cautious.
- [Zach] I just want us to do a good job.
I hope that they don't look at us
and say, like who are these idiots?
- Hopefully we don't f*** it all up.
- [Eugene] It's only four thousand people
that we'd disappoint.
- [Keith] Probably
gonna f*** somethin' up.
- [Ned] But I wanna rock
the f*** out tonight!
I'm also trying not to swear today.
(laughter)
- Alright is this it?
This is it.
- Let's do this.
- [Eugene] Pretty guardians.
- Yeah, were really,
really pretty guardians.
- What's up Anime Expo 2015!
- Woo!
Romance is a waste up here to save space
Setting fires with my grace
giving evil all a taste
and the blaze is hotter than a gaze
from the chips, make a
face I'll read your brain
and burn you just like mace.
- It isn't wit, doesn't fit
I won't like that one bit,
and I'll blush super hot
until my face is totally lit.
But just 'cause I'm embarrassed
doesn't mean that I will quit.
I will blast you with
bubbles like a critical hit.
♫ In the name of Mars I will chastise you
♫ We're Pretty Guardians
♫ Such pretty guardians ♫
- Oh. My. God.
- How're you doing everybody, let's go!
- We melted people's faces off!
- [Keith] Everybody loved
my song, it was perfect-uh.
- Tuxedo mask!
- And our sketch went great,
we were adorable.
- High note is me!
- And I'll make you up
and cut you like a knife!
- I screwed some things up,
I like missed a cue, I missed a line,
no one cared, we just put
all our energy into it,
and we just had a great time.
- Be the scorn that I've sworn
when your band is forlorn.
I'm the muscles of the sailors
and you have been warned!
- So this whole underlying
theme of acceptance
in the cosplay community, I think,
is what really sets it apart
from other subcultures.
And I think that's the
bottom line about cosplay.
- Just come as you are, have fun,
whatever speaks to your heart,
let it out.
People are gonna have
a good time with you.
- You guys are all such an amazing people,
you inspire each other, you inspire us,
thank you for letting us be
a part of this awesome event,
thank you guys so much.
♫ In the name of the moon
♫ We will punish you
♫ We're the Pretty Guardians
♫ Such pretty guardians
♫ In the name of the moon
♫ We will punish you
♫ We're Pretty Guardians
♫ Such pretty guardians
♫ In the name of the moon
♫ We will punish you
♫ We're Pretty Guardians
♫ Such pretty guardians ♫
(audience cheers)
- Thank you Anime Expo!
- Man, I am exhausted.
- Oh, you guys, it was so much work.
- My costume was falling apart all day.
- Mine didn't fall apart,
but then I dropped my goggles
in the urinal.
- What's great about it,
is not one gives a shit.
You really could just be wearing whatever
and if you're like working it,
and you have a passion for it,
someone out there is gonna appreciate it.
- It's such a crazy energy
in this whole place.
So sad we only came one day,
I would have gone the whole weekend!
And oh my goodness, people got engaged!
- Luxray has countered with a held item
it's the destiny knot!
- Will you marry me?
(audience cheers)
- It exemplified the spirit
of this whole weekend.
People sharing their passions,
sharing their love with each other.
- I know I thought about love a lot,
but I really wanna tell her about it,
it's so cute!
- What I've learned is
that I wanna cosplay
more in the future.
- All of us had just such
a great time, I get it.
- I had a great time, this was fun.
I like costumes.
(laughs)
- [All] In the name of the moon,
what will we try next?
- We stay here for a
year, no one will know
we're using our costumes again.
- We get to keep these, right?
'Cause we made 'em.
- Daddy likey.